hello guys you're welcome to the channel
my name is ya and this is ashco TV the
official YouTube channel for AA house
Commodities now guess what I have always
say that Agri business is very very wide
and
Broad now I posted a video in in which I
was
saying that maze planting season is
here talked a lot about maze
farming now something you should also
know is that maybe you don't want to go
into the farming maybe you don't want to
be a farmer right but you still want to
invest in maze or in Agri business in
the direction of
farming in this video I'm going to show
you three very important tools that
farmers really need almost every maze
farmer in Ghana needs this um this this
equipment one way or the other at least
two of two out of three of them every M
farmer needs them or needs the services
of these um tools okay now these are
also avenues that you can go into it you
can buy and rent to these Farmers all
right there are three that I have
identified very critical ones three of
them and I'm going to explain to you
what they what what they does and what
um you can get from it when you decide
decide to invest into them get them and
then rent rent them out to maze Farmers
let's get into the video right now the
first the first tool that I want to
recommend to you that you can go into
you can buy a number of them and
actually rent out to Farmers is maze
planter yes maze Planters okay now what
is happening is that these maze Planters
they are able to help the farmer plant
in straight
rows okay plant in straight rows cuz if
you look at it the the only alternative
apart from using these planter is the
manual planting okay and what happens is
that you're not able to get the rose
very very well you're not going to get
you don't get um straight rolles when
you use the manual you know planting but
with this Planters with this mechanic
Planters you are able to plant in
straight lines and in equal
distance take note of it straight line
and equal distance sometimes you able to
you know plant in straight lines but
what about the distance mind you if you
want to do maze farming and do it very
well you should take all these things
into consideration you should be able to
plant in equal distance because this is
an acre an acre has one size wherever
you go now you know that you are a you
want to plant a certain number of um a
certain number of you know plants on an
acre okay if you use whenever you use
this kind of mechanized you know
Planters you are able to do what to
determine how many plants how many M you
know plants you are going to be able to
plant on an acre you know by knowing the
distance between each of these um these
teets of the road of the plant
all right so these Planters are very
necessary a lot of um Farmers need them
need the services of them and a lot of
farmers are not able to buy them or feel
Rel reluctant buying them because me is
a seasonal crop after the season it will
be ideal for the next before you know
until the next season comes so most
farmers are reluctant about buying them
but they prefer rather renting them
remember we are not going to be able to
give you the price of what of these
equipments these three equipments I'm
talking about okay now what we can give
you is how much you can rent it for so
when you are able to get your price
whatever you you think you can get this
equipment
from then you also look at you know you
you match it with um the the cost of
renting then you'll be able to do your
Ms and know the profit that you can make
out of you know going into um investing
into
this particular
equipment now that being said this
Planters this ma planters for what I
know they are rented for between 50
cities to 100 CI per
acre okay 50 CS to 100 CS per acre okay
and then mind you this is not just one
acre it is going to be you can rent it
out to people who have 5 Acres 10 acres
you know they are a lot all right people
who do large scale farming probably have
Planters you understand so the small
scale farming like 5 Acres 10 acres 6
Acres you know 15 Acres they they are
they should be your target market they
are the people you should be targeting
all right so I can say that in a day you
can rent it out for work for 20 acres
and then you can do this for two three
months you know for the first season and
then maybe two three months also for the
second season so just calculate this by
let's say 5 months in the whole year
then you know how much you can make in a
year right owing just one of of of of
this um Planters all right
now now the second thing I want to
recommend to you the the second
equipment that I or Machinery farm
machinery that I want to recommend to
you
is M the land you know plowing machines
okay plowing machines like last um I
remember last season I made a video
about you know the process of
um our M farm and there were a lot of
questions about you know plowing
machines whenever it is Miss season like
this plowing machines are hot kick
there's no two ways about it and last
season the price for a plowing machine
for an acre the service of a plowing
machine for an acre was 250 CS so this
season we should be looking at 300 CS
for one acre now once again you should
be looking
at um doing you know 50 at least 50 for
a day if you have these Services if if
you have a list of um Farmers that that
needs this Services Ming around you
could do 50 acres in a day a couple just
multiply by at least 250 cities per acre
all right because um the more you know
people gives you work I mean you you you
decide to you know reduce this so let's
let's just say minimum 250 cities by 50
c by 50 aces in a day and you can do
this for like two months in a year no in
a in in in the first season and two
months in the second season we talking
about four months and you can do up to
50 Aces
per day now do your own calculations
I'll just leave it for you to do your
own calculations and go back to Lear to
to see how you're going to get this this
machines because we don't deal in the
machines of course so get you get how to
deal how to get these machines get the
get the cost get do this calculation and
get the possible Revenue that you are
going to make out of it and then strike
and make the possible and get the
possible profit that you can get from
buying this machines all right and I
mind you you're not going to do it for
just one year you can do this for it can
be there for as many years as possible 5
years 10 years the machine will still be
there and you still be making profit out
of
it now surprisingly I just remembered
one other Machinery which a lot of
people have not you know put their mind
it um onto a lot of people have not
considered it but it is very very
essential this is spraying machines
spraying machines now listen in the
village where we were doing our Farms
last
season one spraying machine was 15
CS renting it for a day was 15
CS okay now I don't think this spraying
machine cost more than 500
cities now this machine if well
maintained you can use it for up to 5
years
if well maintained maybe once a while
you have to you know change some the
some few parts of
it but it can be there for a very long
time now just imagine if you have 10 of
them if you have 10 of them which you're
going to buy for like maximum 5,000
cities and you're going to rent each out
for a day
for for 15 cities just make it 10 cities
to break into the
market how much are you going to make in
a month how much are you going to make
in two
months right and how much are you going
to make if four months you're going to
use it for four months in the year for
both seasons of the Year all right do
the calculation but I tell you it is
also very very profitable
right now the last equipment I want to
talk to you about that I want to
recommend that you can go into and
actually invest buy a lot of of it if
not one if not two you know buy a couple
of them and then rent them out which is
also a very very very very very hot kick
of uh Machinery in Agri business
especially in maze farming is treasure
the treasures this this is the machine
that what Treasures or Ser in the final
stage of your Harvest okay now these
machines they are in different you know
they are in different
sizes and capacities but you can get
some that is very very minimal that you
you are you you can you know use it
efficiently for like five to 10 years
also now the now the difference what set
this um tring machine apart from the
other equipment is that for the tring
machine you can even situate it in town
now because come to think of it if
you're looking at the M Planters if
you're looking
at spraying machines if you're looking
at plowing machines you have to be in
farming communities because you have to
be close to where their lands are their
farming lands are that is where you're
going to get them that is where you're
going to you know get to provide these
services but for the treasure for the
mze treasure you can bring it to town
because after harvest after harvest
a lot of these Farmers prefer even
bringing their their produce to the
house and then come and you know Tres
it finally all right so even if you have
this treasure you don't want to go to
the
Farmland maybe some from time to time
you have to go there but you can also
there's also an option of keeping some
in the house and then use it for the
services use it to service all the
farmers that prefer bringing their
produce to what to the house all right
so this is one this is another there a
lot of these equipment but this is the
three four now
four you know that I I wish you can also
go into you could you could get few as
for the spraying machine they are cheap
they are cheap relatively cheap let me
say it that way you know let me choose
my words carefully relatively cheap
we're talking about 5 00 cies machine
that you can rent for like 60 times or
times in a year and you're going to
charge at least 15 cities for one
day you know sometimes you don't have to
be a farmer to benefit from
farming I hope you heard me right
sometimes you don't have to be a farmer
to benefit from farming you can also
provide services that farmers need need
and also what make a business out of it
right so this is ashco TV the official
YouTube channel for a house Commodities
time and time again we will be bringing
you very important business information
that you can you can
adapt and pro and and make a business
out of it
right so this is one side we will bring
you other videos giving you other tips
other practical tips for that matter
right now until we meet in the next one
remember the message has always been one
listen to the
information do your own research and
then get into Agri
business bring out the positive stories
of Agri business and let the Youth of
Africa get to know get
motivated and you know you and I know
what this means you're going to empower
a lot of Youth in Africa to get into
this Noble job of Agri business and um
Feed the World feed themselves and their
families and make a good business out of
it until we meet in the next one my name
is this is Ash TV the official YouTube
channel for a house Commodities bye-bye
for now